字幕: Yuka Kasai
校正: Mai Iida
人と人 心と心が
通い合っている時というのは
私たちはこの上もない幸せを感じるものです
そのために 私は「感謝の心」と
そして常に自己を省みる この「反省の心」
そして 相手を思いやる「敬意の心」
この三つがとても大切だと思います
何故 私がこういう考え方に到ったかというと
昔 大峯千日回峰行という修行を通じて
得た世界観だと思います
千日行とは1日48kmの山道を
1000日間歩き続け
その行が終わると今度は9日間に及び
飲まない、食べない、寝ない、横にならない
という修行を続けます
私は 幼いころ
この修行をある日
テレビで知りました
とても純粋な気持ちで
この修業に「挑戦したい」と思いました
なぜ 10代の子供が
このような修行に
挑戦したいと思ったのかはわかりませんが
小さい頃から みんなが仲良くするためには
どうしたらいいのだろう
そして どうして人と人とは争うのだろう
それを解決するには一体
どうしたら良いのだろう
ということにとても興味を
持っていたからかもしれません
私が挑んだこの千日回峰行を
お話しする前に
少しだけ 日本人が持つ
宗教観についてお話ししたいと思います
この日本という国には
昔から日本人が信じてきた
「神道」という民族の宗教がありました
そこに538年 大陸から「仏教」が伝わって
この二つは共に
排他性と独善性が少ないため
日本において結びつきました
大自然に対しての共存や
感謝の気持ちを大切にする「神道」と
人間がよりよく生きていく為の
生き方を提示してくれる「仏教」が
この日本という国において深く融合し
やがて「和」の精神を
大切にするようになりました
そして 大自然に「生かされている」という
世界でも珍しい考え方をするようになったのです
たとえば 2011年3月11日
この東北という地域に
大きな地震と津波が襲いました
私達は大きな苦しみと
多くの困難を抱えました
深い悲しみの中でも 人々は互いに助け合い
そして食料を分け合い
「和」の精神を大切にして
精一杯生きておりました
その姿が世界中に発信され
「日本人は素晴らしい」と
多くの賞賛を得たと聞いております
震災からしばらくすると
ある海外のメディアが
「この日本という国の人たちは
大自然に生かされている
という考え方を持っていて
いつまでも自然を恨んではいない
これには驚きです」
と コメントしたことが
とても印象的でした
そういう信仰観のある
この日本ならではの修行である
まさに大自然と向き合う
大峰千日回峰行に挑戦するため私は
奈良の吉野山・金峯山寺に向かいました
この行に入ると 一日48kmの山道を
16時間かけて毎日歩き続けなければなりません
そして 5月の3日から9月の3日までの
４ヶ月間を行の期間と定め
その期間は雨が降ろうが嵐が来ようが
どんなに体調が悪かろうが
途中で辞めることができません
もし万が一 途中でやめなければならないと
自分で判断したならば
短刀でもって腹を切って
その場で行を終えるという厳しい掟があります
なぜ そこまで厳しいかというと
たった１日でも48kmは大変なこと
これを千回も続けるということは
死ぬくらいの覚悟がなければ
この行には入ってはいけません という
強い戒めのための掟であり
命を軽んじている
考え方ではありません
行に入ると 毎日23時30分に起床します
そして滝に入り 装束を整え
おにぎり2つと500mlの水を持って
午前0時半 目指す山頂が24km先にある
1719ｍの大峯山山頂を目指します
途中 急な斜面や
断崖絶壁のような悪路もあり
まさに一瞬一瞬が命がけです
山頂到着が朝の8時30分
そこでおにぎりと水を補給し
また来た道をたどって帰ってくると
夕方の3時半
そこから掃除、洗濯
次の日の用意をして
また4時間半ほどの睡眠で
この４ヶ月を通します
一日のほとんどがおにぎりと
水で生活しますので
一か月ほどで 栄養失調で
ぼろぼろと爪が割れてきます
三か月目になると 40度以上を超える
気温の中 歩きますので
血尿が出てしまいます
山では熊、猪、マムシが
いつ襲ってくるかわかりません
そういった中を 日々精一杯
前を向いて歯を食いしばって
修行をいたします
行の中で 私は
心に思ったことを
日記に書きつづっていました
それを拝読してみたいと思います
17日目
“行者なんて次の一歩が分からないんだ
行くか行かないかじゃあない
行くだけなんだ
理屈なんか通りやあしない
もし行かなけりゃあ 短刀で腹を切るしかない
そう 次の一歩が分からないんだ”
行に入ると肉体的 精神的には非常に
日々 極限状態に追い込まれます
しかし 心の中はいつも潤っていました
それは何故かというと
自分がこの行を通して 精一杯努力をして
何か 世界の人たちのために
何かお役にたてるような人間になりたいと
いつも心の中で強く 夢や希望に
満ち溢れていたからかもしれません
しかし 1300年の中でまだ一人しか
達成していないというこの修行は
困難を極めました
最低３回は生きるか死ぬかの
試練があると言われております
まず１回目は 大きながけ崩れに
巻き込まれそうになったこと
２回目は熊に襲われかけたこと
そして３回目は
488日目から10日で
11kgも痩せてしまうという体調不良でした
489日
“腹いたい　たまらん
体中のふしぶしが痛くたまらん
道端に倒れ 木に寄りかかり
涙と汗と鼻水を垂れ流し
でも人前では毅然と
俺は人に希望を与えさせて頂く仕事
人の同情を買うようでは行者失格だと言い聞かせ
やっと蔵王堂に帰ってきた
なんで48km歩けたんだろう
さっき近所のおばちゃんが
「軽い足取りやねえ 元気そうやねえ」と
俺は「はい ありがとうございます」
と答えたが 本当は違うんだよ
俺の舞台裏は 誰も知る人はいないだろう
いや 知ってくれなくていい
誰に見られることを意識しない
野に咲く一輪の花のごとく
御仏に対し ただ
清く正しくありたい”
何日も高熱が出て何も食べることができず
そして私は495日目
とうとう山の中で力尽き
闇の中に倒れてしまいました
その時の心境はというと
辛いとか苦しいとかという感覚は
全くありませんでした
そして何かにくるまれているような
そういう感覚でした
そして朝を迎えたら
自分がここで死を迎えると
自分で感じておりました
すると 幼い頃からの記憶が蘇り
いろんな人にお世話になった事を思い出し
こんなところで倒れてはいけない と
強く前に進んだから
今の自分がここにあります
人間が生死を彷徨うような体験をすると
人生観が変わると言いますけれども
その後 書きつづった日誌を読んでみましょう
563日
“人間は皆平等であると思います
この地球に生まれ
空気も、水も、光も
平等に与えられていることを
感謝しなければならないと思います
夜空の星の数は 人間が一生かかっても
数えきれないといいます
それを考えたならば もっと心豊かに
生きていかなければならないと思いました
自分の胸に手をやれば心臓が動いています
しかし 永遠に動いていることはないと思えば
人生という与えられし限られた時間を
大切に生きれるはずです
自分を大切にするように
他人をも尊重するということも
忘れてはいけないと思います
思いやりの心が
私たちに幸せをもたらす道です
朝起きる、歩く、食べる、寝る
人間生活の原点にかえり
たった一人お山にいると
こんな事を考えてしまいます”
「同じことを同じように繰り返して
情熱を持って毎日を過ごしていると
悟る可能性がある」と
今から2500年前
釈尊が言われました
ここに行の意味があります
日々 汗し涙し
そして歯を食いしばり歩いていると
「人間として大切なものは何か」ということに
自分が気がつき始めます
その極限の世界で感じたことが
「感謝の心」であり
「反省の心」であり
相手を思いやる「敬意の心」
しかし こういうことは
とても日常 当たり前のことであって
小さい頃 家庭で教わるようなことです
けれども 自分自身が
本当に生きるか死ぬかの瀬戸際になったときに
「こういうことが大事だったんだ」
ということが
心の奥底で実感できるように
なるのであります
大切なのは あらゆる存在との
調和だと思います
我々一人一人は かけがえのない存在であります
誰でも 自分が可愛くて
自分が大切です
だからこそ 自分を大切にするように
人を尊重するという事を
第一に考えなければなりません
心から相手を思いやる
その思いやりの心や
言葉や 行動が
人と人とをつなぎ合わせ
その功徳が回り回って
自分の心を潤し
そして 我々が光ある人生へと
導かれていくことでしょう
争い対立からは
心の喜びは生まれません
今 与えられたこの環境を真摯に受け入れて
向き合ってみることも大切です
向き合うことによって
初めて 何かが生まれます
そして絆が深まります
もちろん 向き合うことによって
様々な問題を抱えてしまったり
困難を抱えてしまうかもしれません
しかし 互いに尊重し合い
敬意を払い
話し合うことによって
そこで新しい方向性が
見えてくる場合もあります
私たち この東北人も
大きな困難と向き合い
そして絆を深めてきたからこそ
今ここまで復興してまいりました
日本人はよくあいまいだと
言われますけれども
決してそんなことはありません
多岐にわたる選択肢の中から
人と人とをつなげて
そして良き方向へと
考えられる民族です
この「和」の精神を
日本の 東北から
発信していかなければならないと私は思います
世界中の人と人
そして国と国 宗教や文化が
互いに敬意の心をもって
お互いを尊重し
そしてすばらしい世界が
この世の中に実現することを
心から深く願います
世界の平和や
我々一人一人の人生に幸あれと
みんなで祈りましょう
そして今日も世界のどこかで
食料が無く大変な思いをしている人たち
こういう人たちのために
何かできる範囲内で
私たちが行動を
おこなさなければならない時期だと思います
心を広く持ってみましょう
この大自然は 微妙でかつ
素晴らしいバランスでもって
包み込まれております
人間がどのような技術を持ってしても
作られない 素晴らしい世界に
包まれています
ここにいることだけでも
感謝だと思います
そして 人と人
心と心が通い合った時
私たちはこの上もない幸せを
感じるものだと思います
そのために 私たちは
この地球に生まれてきたんだと思います
皆さんの人生に幸あれと心から願います
ありがとうございました